et on va retrouver avec plaisir en
direct de bercy france gall bonsoir
bonsoir
alors pour mieux voir de votre spectacle
dans combien de temps les vues sur scène
et bien dans 35 minutes si les 8h25
il est 8h 29 dans 20 30 minutes en 30
minutes on va peut-être avoir quelques
minutes de retard c'est le premier jour
donc ça m'étonnerait que ça commence à
l'heure le train part dans le trac je
dirais pas le trac mais il se dirait
plutôt une grande émotion
oui c'est ça plutôt c'est beaucoup
d'émotion je ressens et je ne veux pas
me laisser submerger par l'émotion parce
que la répétition générale tout à
l'heure ça m'est arrivé et dans ce cas
là je peux pas chanter donc c'est
dramatique pour les gens qui viennent
voir une chanteuse quand même avant que
je suis en un extrait de votre
répétition avant oui déjà de votre
répétition regarde on gagne quoi
c'était
ce gaza
pitié
sans creuser du mans
france gall vous avez dit il ya un
instant émotion est ce que pauline et
raphaël seront dans la salle et pauline
et raphaël seront la lier à fallait pas
loin je ré tous les gens que j'aime et
qui m'aiment dans la salle ce soir plus
tous ceux que je ne connais pas et je
suis très très très très impressionné
par par sa barre par tout cet amour qui
est dégagé de tout ces gens je le dis
pour les téléspectateurs pauline et
rafael sont vos enfants
oui france gall il ya une certaine
presse très impudique qui a exploité à
l'extrême ce qui vous est arrivé
récemment comment avez vous pu résister
à ce que j'appellerais un bon lloris mme
je n'ai pas pu résister ça s'est emparé
cette presse s'est emparée de moi tout
comme ce cancer s'est emparée de moi
mais j'espère bien qu'elle va me lâcher
maintenant que le cancer m'a lâché donc
ça devrait rentrer dans l'ordre
tout ça qui sont ces jeunes danseurs qui
vont danser qu'on a vu et qui vont
danser ce soir avec vous ils viennent de
la banlieue qui dansent à bercy c'est la
banlieue qui déboule sur la scène de
bercy c'est des personnes qui font
vraiment partie de la vie maintenant ça
doit pas être des exclus ils ont apporté
créer une mode une façon de bouger une
façon de s'habiller une façon de chanter
leur appétit le sport et puis c'est des
gens avec qui je me sens bien et que
j'ai eu envie d'avoir autour de moi sur
scène et je les adore voilà on va
s'embarquer pendant un petit moment
comme ça ensemble
merci france gall ça se voit et ça
s'entend vous êtes enfant bousquet de
takk merci de m'avoir aussi au revoir on
voit